[Applause]
oh my god
all thanks for my kitchen nick how you
doing very very well i'm very excited
actually
excited i want to beat everybody hello
what's your strengths
um i'm always very calm so i'm hoping
that
i'll be able to cope with everything
that accent's very sexy talk to me again
my dad's watching meet tonight's family
brigade
the appleton blatts all saints wild
child turned domestic goddess nick is
the youngest daughter of mum mary who
collects recipe books
and loves cooking with them in the
kitchen is fellow pop star and best mate
mel
who reckons she's a better cook than a
rock chick french mum helen
who cooks up creative dishes every night
[Music]
[Applause]
they'll be serving three courses to 50
diners and the food will need to be
perfect
if they're gonna be my number one
brigade
okay starter angel hair pasta with clams
now the most important thing about these
dams uh highly seasonal
yeah absolutely delicious what we've got
to save is the juice okay right shots in
okay garlic in and a chilean the secret
of cooking clams is doing it quickly
so we sort of park roast them part steam
them
right clams in yes roll that round
okay then from there white wine in
there's a whole lot a whole lot okay
that's the noise
here yeah if we haven't got the noise in
there we're just going to boil them give
it a little shake
lid on pasta in right now our fresh
basil
be careful it's pasta but it's
translucent completely clear it's cooked
but literally two and a half to three
minutes and boiling water they've opened
now just started to steam over just
smell
right i love it i absolutely love so out
we drain them very quickly right stop
back in
okay we're gonna reduce that down
literally 30 seconds
it's all so simple if you listen to me
and we work together
yeah we're gonna get there okay clams
the most exciting thing about this dish
is
it's very healthy and they're low in fat
toss the pasta in
when we're serving this up nice twister
pasta in the middle i don't want one
with all the clams in one all the
spaghetti the other want it nicely
evenly done okay a little taste jesus
christ nick
right will you stop eating because you
won't be moving in two minutes time yes
you're here to cook not to eat jesus
christ okay
good luck yes i know what a [ __ ]
table five four
right so two little balls of pasta per
portion yes so can we
put them together yeah absolutely make
sure the water's boiling rapidly first
though yes
good smell so far you've eaten more than
you served
mary okay you with me i'm with you
too much garlic on it too much garlic oh
[ __ ] me
it tastes alright to me are they are
they cooked now yeah
good good good good i've wrapped my
finger already
thing stop eating it i'm eating it
really good yeah less garlic i know
you're french but let's garlic yes
table five please go pop it off please
mine's done i need a plate
so four more as quick as you can yeah
let's see what jenna street farm has
been up to this week
in a quiet corner of the yorkshire dales
the piece has been shattered
yes
[Music]
janet street porter's on a mission to
get us all eating british veal
janet's veal calves are now two months
old they're getting through 13 liters of
milk each a day
and like all young males her balls are
getting thirsty and frisky
come on get on the case fighting over
one bucket
i can't believe this one look at him
just that total bully
but feel has an image problem i'm on the
wall path again
and i want to get british feel back on
the menu
i want to tell people that the images of
the ill treatment of animals are not
only inaccurate that they're just
plain history many people don't know
that they can buy cruelty-free british
roseville
rather than farmville that can be
intensively reared
it's actually great to eat it
and it's perfectly humane to rear it
even in this rural yorkshire village
there are very few who actually eat it
meal no way wow
i have never eaten veal being a lot of
who are about it aren't it you know
my dad's a butcher and he doesn't sell
meal that i want to eat it
janet is determined to educate people
about this fantastic and
under-appreciated meat
[Music]
she's starting at grassroots with the
next generation of meat-eaters
hello don't look frightened
as ever janet decides to go for the
gentle approach
in a few months time they're going to go
to the slaughterhouse
and we're going to slaughter them and
then we're going to eat them
[Music]
around half a million bull calves are
born each year as a byproduct of the
dairy industry
because they're boys they can't make
milk it's their only use is to be eaten
because we don't eat much british veal
many bull cars get shipped off on long
journeys to europe
i've bought them so they're growing up
here in nidadale
yeah you like it don't you do you want
to stroke them
come on in that one he's so nice there's
aren't you anything left
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's really important for kids to know
where their meat comes from if janet can
get this lot interested in veal
perhaps their parents will start cooking
it at home
do they have good shelter
yes i bet you the size of their room
their living room is bigger than most of
ours
do they make milk no they don't if they
were clever enough to make milk
they wouldn't be slaughtered they would
be cats because we all want milk
all right they poo and they've stopped
having the runs now
stopped having diarrhoea all the time
not very nice
but they did wipe their bottoms on the
wall
[Laughter]
well thanks very much if you all enjoyed
meeting them yeah
bye bye looks like she's got the local
kids on side
but janet's not going to stop there
not until everyone's heard a message
loud and clear
shut up we're not bloody well there yet
right hello and [ __ ] famous good girl
head off is that right and your
youth used to be a hippy long time ago
yeah and you took mao to glastonbury
when she was little right
how old was she when she went there five
amazing you must remember if the times
haven't opened after that length of
cooking yeah
okay they've gone off so don't serve
closed clams okay
the garlic and the chili and the parsley
was perfect the sauce was lovely the
pasta was light
now how are we very well right how was
your starter bombshells there were quite
a few
clothes which were quite disappointing
damn they shouldn't be closed what about
the ones that were open how were they
they were very nice very flavorful
well sometimes as they um open and then
sometimes they're attracted and closed
as well so it's not because they're off
or they're stale
but we shouldn't have certain clothes
spotted there really sorry i hope you
enjoyed the main course thanks good to
see you
it's not that bad lovely
really cooked well the parsley the
garlic the chili
the ancient pasta was very flavoursome i
would definitely be happy to pay for it
it's really tasty
right helen how well do you think you
did starters yeah i think about 46.
46. twice a month we are riding behind
that conference right jose
tough out there yes yeah so the amount
of customers that are happy to pay
you know out of 50 for the starter
3950 yeah well done it's not bad trust
me
11 that's not paying well a lot of them
had a closed
clams closed plate did you check them
all nick i did
mel you didn't check yours tam that's
why 10 aren't paying for it because you
sent them with [ __ ] clothes
[Music]
next on the menu the royal marines
helped me work up a healthy appetite
that was the longest 30 minutes my
entire [ __ ] life
and the appleton blacks cook a delicious
spiced pork chop with crushed sweet
potatoes
but will my diners like it my missus
does a better sweet salad than you
actually [ __ ] good
[Applause]
welcome back yes word now come to the
main course spice pork chop with crushed
sweet potatoes
[Music]
it's moist it's tender and it's
absolutely delicious
marinade chili powder paprika
coriander seeds star anise
crush thyme garlic
olive oil salt pepper
mix pork chops
marinade chill
hot pan olive oil pork chops into the
pan
color on both sides tilt the pan
and baste
into the oven 8 to 10 minutes 200
degrees
sweet potatoes peel chop
chicken stock boil
[Applause]
drain hot pan olive oil
shallots garlic
season lightly caramelize the slots
that helps to sweeten the potatoes up
even more sweet potatoes
crush finish it with some fresh
coriander and sage
[Applause]
[Music]
mix what a delicious way of eating sweet
potato
pork chops out
rest
[Applause]
[Music]
sweet and delicious classic spiced pork
chops with crushed sweet potatoes
done right mary
at the pan they've got to be seasoned
first before they go in there quick
pour in there salt and pepper yep that's
it take off
so as you put them in you lay away from
you and
the most important thing about cooking
this meat on the bone it becomes nice
okay and nice and sort of tender okay
because the bone
okay it's giving it a lot of flavor
right in the oven to go
okay helen yeah yes
look at me yeah look look wait you start
your potatoes what's going on first
come on help me
once we cook them they've got to rest if
they don't rest
okay they're going to be raw in the
middle they must rest okay
okay good nice hot pan now when we crush
them i don't want to puree
just nice and lightly crushed helen how
old was mel when she first showed an
interesting food
um well she was about five about five
really yeah
this is that dandelion and a rocket yeah
i'm fed up with everyone leaving
dandelion to the [ __ ] rabbits yeah we
should be eating more of it
so rock it in good nice that's for four
good
don't worry about the pepper just the
salt yeah because the rocket's naturally
peppery yeah
come on ladies we can do this yes yep
and then from there off here out
straight away good watch
from there on there like that yeah okay
pork chop
just lay it on on top right now like
that yeah exactly
standing up lift up your wilted
dandelion rocket
i'm just on just on top
good right a little bit olive oil let me
show the olive oil now around here
are you happy with that yeah good good
very nice very very nice go take seven
please let's go
all right
i've run nine marathons open 18
restaurants but i've never ever done
anything
as tough as this
[Music]
the royal marines are one of the world's
elite fighting forces
their training regime is grueling so
they need all the energy they can get
from the food they eat
these recruits have been pushed to their
absolute physical and mental limits
i'm dying to find out what fuel actually
keeps them going look at them they look
absolutely hard as nails i'm meeting
corporals ben slater and tim richards
who served in iraq and afghanistan and
are currently down in devon to train up
the new recruits
good to see you both these recruits
train like maniacs and eat like horses
but the food they're given is bland and
boring it's the quality of the food that
it's important recruits here for 32
weeks and they're going to the same
meals day in day out it gets quite
mundane
i'm here to show them that simple
healthy food with all the nutrition that
they need
can be tasty too but first they're going
to teach me a lesson nervous
head down and get on with it i'm going
to join 20 recruits on the rugged
terrain of woodbury common for today's
exercise
the endurance course so time-wise how
long does it take to do this thing
well if we can get off the tunnels
course itself under 25 minutes
yeah we'll be both happy the only
problem is i'm running late as pti
corporal reggie redrop lets me know
go ramsay get down here move right
ramsey you won't be pressed up she's
late
sorry how many please 100. later
all the way down ramsay
it's always that miserable first in the
morning does your cracker smile
[ __ ] me stand by
three two one go i may be twice as old
as these young recruits
but there's no way i'm gonna let that
affect my performance right let's have a
good time here that ramsay yeah
the recruits obviously find it hard i
think he's going to find a special time
there'll be times there
where he will not want to carry on this
course
is all about endurance you run in teams
of three and each man has to carry a
sa-80 assault rifle
and equipment weighing in at 32 pounds
within minutes
i was feeling the pain
[Music]
for breath we reached the sheep dip
here's where that famous marines
teamwork kicks in
okay after a lung full of air
i get to return the favor good effort
grab your weapons
[Music]
a royal marine recruits daily intake is
over four thousand calories a day
nearly twice that of an average male
beginning to understand why they need
quite so much fuel
utterly knackered we reach the smarty
tubes and my heart sinks when i realise
which one they're sending me through
come round you get a move on hold
everyone off for [ __ ] sake
get him involved ramsey move your ass
time's sticking on
without the feed and all that think
about them become motivation let's go
down all your weapons ramsay gonna move
on
well they gotta keep it going man you're
not getting yourself stuck in that time
aren't you
oh there he is
[Music]
34 minutes and three seconds ramsay that
is shocking
what they used to do lead boots i've not
broken any records
but at least i didn't come last that has
to be the hardest course i've ever been
on ever
from marathons to double marathons you
name it that was the longest 30 minutes
my entire [ __ ] life
yeah guys are amazing i mean that's what
we call fit
back to base to get into warm dry
clothes then it's time for me to teach
them a lesson
in cooking these guys aren't fueling
their body with the right food they've
got no chance of getting through a day's
training
let alone 32 [ __ ] weeks what are you
eating in the field we have 10 man
russian pack
breakfast sausage and beans sausage and
beans very nice [ __ ] me look at that
it's like inside a [ __ ]
nappy holy crap
prince harry was complaining about it
recently on service in afghanistan yeah
which i mean it's a far cry coming out
of buckingham palace yeah you guys
deserve better
right we're going to do something uh
exciting yeah spicy beef curry
after putting meat to the test it's now
my turn to give the orders
for this substantial dish we're gonna
use rump steak which is high in protein
cut it in half and what we're gonna do
now is get these really nice large
cubes
[Music]
have you ever been out looked at the
rations and just said [ __ ] that i'm not
eating that yeah yes
quite a cozy glass would take out their
own stuff herbs spices tabasco
take the taste off what you're eating
[Music]
marinade the beef and garam masala
yoghurt olive oil
and salt and pepper now we're going to
chop the onions a whole lot the whole
lot
great fresh garlic and ginger over the
onions i can think of the
indigestion eating all those [ __ ]
rations
so ginger is a welcome spice
add chilis sugar to help caramelise the
onions followed by coriander cardamom
and ground spice
dry roasting will help intensify the
flavor
[Music]
mix fennel coriander cumin and fenugreek
seeds which are rich in dietary fiber
and soothe the stomach
quickly color the marinaded beef to seal
in the flavors
that's the noise i want to hear
[Music]
mixing the beef adding chopped tomatoes
and tomato puree so the tomato paste
goes in
in place of any sort of cream of butter
so it's a really nice healthy way of
eating a spicy curry
stock in that's a normal beef stock the
spicy beef curry is then left to simmer
before being served with rice
a virtually fat and cholesterol-free
slow-release energy source
[Music]
gentlemen come on guys
is that it is it now i've got put a
spice in yours yeah those [ __ ] press
ups this morning do you want to spit in
here
already i'm sure these guys are half my
age right
yeah i didn't come last that's the most
important are you happy
yeah yeah yeah really nice though i'm
gonna do tarzan next time
i'm gonna give you a [ __ ] run for
your money
come on granddad
it's [ __ ] freezing
mary these chops look fantastic by the
way really good color
very nice helen got another plate
beautiful let's go
all tonight's recipes on the website so
get off the sofa and get cooking
good next table is liam yes yep what do
you think about me with your haircut
i love it i can see his face it's almost
beautiful finally yeah
what's like bowl do you cut that with
that can liam cook
yeah he can actually can he cook better
than robbie
well he doesn't eat pies
you're eating again this is liam's dish
madam right your name yeah i know
no [ __ ] eat here before it gets to
your table i'm so sorry i'm starting my
life mate
will you please yeah yeah you recognize
him the one with the pork chops side
burns
nice sweet potatoes and then i have the
dandelion
last table one table two to get paint
ladies
do you remember guys if that's something
brave my mom took you yeah i played
violin
what's your cool hippie no
no does such a thing exist as a cool
hippie anyway
okay
holy [ __ ] go well done in one second
mary well done
hey good to see you and you've probably
shooting
how you doing yeah very hot yeah chilled
out oh no you would pick a food
your [ __ ] sweet potatoes bobbins one
because my missus does better than that
i said bobbins means what [ __ ] yeah yeah
because it's a bit clumpy and like comfy
yeah it was all really nice but my
missus does a better sweet sale than you
actually [ __ ] good day yeah you sold
that cookie that way how do you think
you and your
brother would get on through in the
kitchen i reckon he's ed would be firmly
pressed against one of them up things
are you mellowing now in your 40s
yeah without doubt the kids are involved
though yeah this is we're all just
buzzing yeah but i mean it just takes me
longer to recover from
my mental nights out and our mental
nights out and not this at worst she's
just as [ __ ] mad as me
is she yeah without a dartmouth yeah
what's the new haircut
i'm just gradually like you know [ __ ] it
you know i mean tonight i'm gonna
[ __ ] shave her off from [ __ ] most
nicole said she's done it with a frying
pan a bit like a pudding bowl but that's
that one what my hair
was yeah she didn't cut that did she
come on get off you got [ __ ] yours
you look like you've been electrocuted
you [ __ ] i've been struck by lightning
i really like the dandelions they were
brilliant haven't had those before
i thought the pork chop was excellent
really well cooked succulent and juicy
right time for the results yes all right
mary how well do you think you did main
course
what are you saying 47 optimistic happy
eater male
1 well i ate all of them about 50. 50.
right jose results please yes demanding
difficult customers
okay results the number of customers
that pays
50 out of five
[Applause]
that's the first time this series has
happened
well done christ almighty
okay we knew where everything was and we
felt more confident maybe slightly
i loved it it was good it was it felt
easier
this time around everything seems to
just click
and uh it's a rhythm almost i think
it was great i was very surprised how
well we pulled together
next on the menu it's [ __ ] pitch
black now i'm on night maneuvers in
gloucestershire on the hunt for elvis
the brigade cooker scrumptious apple
tart with caramelised cream
and i get to grill the former home
secretary in the recipe challenge
your current girlfriend is a doctor
right do you enjoy her bedside manner
rephrase that or i'll punch you now
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the f word time for the
recipe challenge now we've always had
blind tasters but tonight
i've got a blind cook david blunter you
look great by the way well you're a star
as well what are you doing i'm doing um
shepherd's pie now are you feeling
confident less confident than i ever do
in the out of commons or on the
political stump
so talk me through the recipe how's it
gonna work the recipe is that i'm i'm
chopping the carrots
and then i'm gonna put those in yeah
with the onions
in a little bit of olive oil david's
chopping is this one i'm gonna grate my
vegetables i want to grate the
vegetables first the carrots the onions
and the garlic
soda them off a little bit olive oil so
they sort of thicken and almost puree
which gives a really nice thick base to
the shepherd's pie what's your favorite
food what'd you enjoy eating
i enjoy lamb which is why i've got
shepherd's pie rather than
cottage pie my mother would do necolam
ready
she did something called hash which
actually was like an irish you're a
lancashire
pop were you a big fan of hash i was a
great fan of that then you grew up and
legalized it
um thank you very much which is nothing
nothing of the sort
but we'll pass on that one i brought
some herbs from my garden by the way
i'm gonna chop rosemary and a bit of
sage because i'm i'm
you know really keen on sage right i'm
gonna fry off my onions and my garlic
in hot oil well i'm a bit behind you but
don't worry
i don't want to distract you you are
distracting me i'm sorry you're a great
distractor
well that's part of the technique that's
my secret absolutely huh
right i've got fresh rosemary sweaty
down with the vegetables
that gives it a really nice earthy
flavor right this is the dangerous bit
for the fingers
oh really yeah because i've got to get
this mince in
and i've got to make sure that it's in
the pan and not
all over the cooker okay a little bit of
fresh thyme
in with the mince well i'm doing the
stock just putting a little bit of stock
in
it is a problem if you put too much yeah
because it goes so
soggy horrible well then you're
definitely lose
yes you're not nice you politicians are
competitive come on
yeah we we are in our own chef's office
and what was the food like in the
cabinet
well we never really got fed the perks
were a 16 hour day
six and a half days a week when i was
home secretary that's not even being a
chef but
well
did you ever invite the cabinet round
for a dinner party at home i did
i'm gonna invite tony and sherry gordon
and sarah
oh nice they weren't all there that
would have been a dinner to remember
wouldn't it
uh yes holy mackerel um now i'm just
going to have a look at my recipe
i've got it in braille were you amazed
when you heard about
john prescott's bulimia yes
but we're all amazing people we never
know anything about each other
it looks as though i need to put my p's
in
okay peace all right um are you still in
touch with tony
i am indeed what's his favorite food
what do you enjoy eating well actually
they didn't they didn't eat all that
well i mean they have takeaways and
are you telling me tony blair is a big
kebab fan
he can afford to eat well but that's not
the same thing as eating well
no so there we go what about gordon
brown he enjoys his food doesn't he
gordon doesn't have time for food he's
too busy for food
i've added my mince to my vegetables
because he lays the pan now a little bit
of red wine give it some body
more importantly some color reduce the
red wine down and then add my stock
bring it to the boil season it i'll be
ready for the mashed potatoes
i'm not putting wine no and firstly
because i think it's just
it's sacrilegious and second it actually
flavors the meat too much
i'm a chef so you're telling me now how
to cook my [ __ ] shepherd's pie i like
that
200 ml of chicken stock in bring it up
to the ball and that will give it a
really nice sort of
rich flavor get it a little bit more
savory with some
worcester sauce i'm going to do
henderson's relish because it's made in
sheffield it's vegetarian and it's much
better yeah it's not a relish though is
it it's like a
worcester sauce yeah yeah now crush
potatoes egg yolks in that gives it a
really nice
richness to the top of the shepherd's
pie
and then grate some parmesan cheese in
there this is where we differ because
i'm not doing the egg yolk
or the cheese spoon and spoon them on
you see this dish yes same as yours is
it yeah it is actually
how the hell are we going to tell the
difference your dish and my dish if i
lose
i'd swear we have dna you add mine okay
we'll have a dna test on the shepherd's
pie
excellent right
right you get your mints into the tray
now i'm gonna ask you to put my potato
of course i will i i would take about 10
minutes over it
i i can really [ __ ] it up then and then
i can wear it are you happy with the
taste the potato yeah the potatoes are
fine it's worked some sweden
is that okay sweet now your um your
current girlfriend is a doctor right
my partner is a doctor lovely do you
enjoy her bedside manner
i uh rephrase that or i'll punch you in
there
how are you doing i'm just kidding oh
that's all right are you fluffing it up
a bit yeah yeah just to
get a bit of air into it absolutely yeah
okay davies is going on the top
with a tray so it doesn't contaminate
mine mine's going
on the bottom 20 minutes yes david takes
the dog for a walk comes back
finds he's been voted out of my kitchen
and loses
now there are some ingredients you can
buy and there are some you have to stay
up all
[ __ ] night for
for most of the year the river 7 flows
peacefully through 220 miles of british
countryside
until this happens
the seven bore a phenomenal tidal wave
that charges in from the north atlantic
and carries with it one of the most
mysterious and fascinating delicacies
i've ever come across
years ago elves used to be a poor man's
food they literally cost 50p a pint and
millions of them swept through the river
seven every night now today's different
story stocks are down by 98
and tonight i'll be lucky if i can
[ __ ] catch two dozen
elves or baby eels have a unique
delicate flavor
they taste like a lighter version of eel
and have a slight sweetness like
scallops and lobster
they swim upstream at night to avoid
predators so the only way to catch them
is under the cover of dark
i've enlisted the help of a local
fisherman richard cook
i've been a lot of searches yeah but not
in the dark what the [ __ ] are we doing
here tonight we're going to attempt to
catch alvarez yeah
baby or fry at the seventh yeah not
possible during the day
not during the day no no this is our
only chance uh how long is it going to
take to catch them
well i think it'll be daybreak honestly
yes i think throughout the whole night i
think we will be here all night yeah
serious yeah what in the [ __ ] is that
it's like a bathtub on a stick
holy crap huh that's what you're
wielding tonight big net big catch right
yeah i can't come back empty-handed you
will not come back empty-handed
elves can fetch up to 300 pounds per
kilo so a very good night's catch can be
worth several thousand pounds
fishermen like richard have to take
extreme care to keep their fishing spots
secret
due to an increasing number of illegal
poachers trying to muscle in
you know alvin's not all about you know
it's not all about earning money
no no no it's a way of life you know
historically it was never perceived as a
delicacy
it was an important source of protein
for poor people yeah
the aristocracy owned and the landowners
owned the salmon fishing and the sea
tree fishing
the poor own the alvin yeah absolutely
she had to look forward to it
yeah every year each and every year it's
getting harder to find them
more expensive to buy them elves are so
rare that fishing them is controlled
heavily by the environment agency
i've been granted a license oh there's
some in there gordon you've caught your
first
four hours four hours [ __ ] you now
honestly i can't believe the size of the
[ __ ] net for four small elves
christ almighty these incredible
creatures are carried in the gulf stream
thousands of miles to the uk
all the way from the north atlantic
sargasso sea
those that aren't caught will one day
make an attempt at a return journey in
order to breed
[ __ ] you know this is a labor of love
you know that well that's [ __ ] four
more
that's four plus five that's nine [ __ ]
me they look like giant sperm
just under an hour four
basically 35 [ __ ] elves
they're pretty gruesome in terms of uh
look
presentation flavor-wise they are
[ __ ] delicious
i'm catching so few elvis for my efforts
thankfully richard gets a call from one
of the network of his trusted friends
also fishing out on the seven giving him
details of a potential shoal
further up the river
that was the most fantastic spot no that
was disappointing start
yeah yeah half 12 at night so where are
we going now we're going to go to an
area called the stank
the 8-week window for catching elvis is
extremely small which explains why
competition is fierce
and information on where to catch them
is kept secret
this is like an undercover network here
it is we all have people that we speak
to
it's like governed by the [ __ ]
mafiosa it [ __ ] is
are there areas where you won't fish on
uh there are areas where i would be very
nervous to go yeah
serious i'm beginning to understand how
territorial and competitive fishing for
elvis is
it's clear we're not the only ones
receiving tip-offs so in order to divert
unwanted attention
we go know him dark don't know him now
he's [ __ ] extraordinary this we've
been followed now two of the vehicles
coming on board is that because they
think that we're going to a hot spot
yeah we're catching they think there's
fish down here so they're now following
us
[ __ ] you now right right here we go what
we're going to do if we meet some
[ __ ] muscle heads hey and if i'm on
somebody else's patch
yeah you're on your own jesus christ
it's [ __ ] pitch black no
huh do we say good evening to them over
there or not no
no don't say anything how's the fishing
going guys
oh say they're worse than chefs hey
they don't talk to us [ __ ] hell
that's not too bad though i mean i know
it's a delicacy and yeah totally [ __ ]
get it
but jesus christ it's an extraordinary
man at work
they don't come for free do they we've
been at it now for nearly two hours and
look
[ __ ] you now thank [ __ ] they're
delicious you know that
go on your bastards jump in there that's
better
no yeah no yeah it's not bad bad is it
a move up river starts to pay off as my
catch becomes much more respectable
we're getting there anyway aren't we
yeah we're done somebody would be glad
of that for a feed
yeah there's a lot of back work isn't it
yeah yeah
we're going the right way okay guys how
are we doing
yeah slacking off a little bit and uh
that water's dropped down again time to
call it a night don't you think what'd
you reckon
well 3 30.
fair shot yeah four hours yeah for the
amount of hard work that's gone into
that
it doesn't look like a lot but has a
nice catch
i've managed to net about 75 pounds
worth just enough for a modest breakfast
they're beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right it's 26 in the morning and i'm now
going to cook these little [ __ ] on
toast
for my fisherman are you hungry yeah
okay elva's on toast chop the shallots
nice and thin
garlic it's really important when you
cook elvis to get everything ready
because they cook
in literally seconds
bread in season with salt and pepper
add the shallot and a clove of garlic
nice
a piece of paper to drain this is where
we make the flour mix
to take the elvis to a different leaf
powdered mustard
cayenne pepper that gives a little bit
of heat salt and pepper
[Music]
now the elbows are gonna have a little
bath washing them through
[Applause]
oh look the dryer we get them the
crisper they become
elves have a wonderful texture and
flavor and this coating will give them a
crispy outside
to complement the smoothness of the
flesh
[Music]
the new little [ __ ] are going in the
pan
putting them straight into the pan is
the quickest way of killing them
frying like this ensures the elves keep
their unique flavor
very very quick parsley
salt and pepper lemon and they literally
take seconds
for them bingo get your elbows
on to the toast
gentlemen six hours to catch 30 seconds
to cook
here we go yeah
i'm gorgeous you can see why it's such a
delicacy now can't he
so same turns out then i'll call you
right time for the dessert apple tart
fiend with caramel ice cream
this has to be the simplest and the most
delicious dessert in britain today
puff pastry cut
prick it with a fork and this stops the
pastry
from bubbling up braeburn apples they
don't hold
lots of juice so therefore it doesn't
make the tart soggy core
peel slice
layer
[Music]
butter sugar
cover the apples completely and then
straight into the oven
190 to caramelise
beautiful a light dusting of icing sugar
[Applause]
[Music]
blow torch and just lightly
glaze those apples
[Music]
and then finally to the ice cream
[Music]
[Applause]
that has to be the best looking tart in
britain
apple tart fiend with caramel ice cream
done
if we win we get to come back yeah oh
[ __ ] we want to come back
we want to come back yes are you a
natural blonde
uh yes you are do you want us to show
you
what am i doing i'm putting more of
these on you're making me nervous
have you changed now yes since you've
become a mum how about you how's life
changed yeah
oh yes it hurts i feel guilty all the
time now yeah
guilt because i go out with mail i work
i shouldn't work work is healthy no i
know and he loves me he doesn't mind me
working yeah
right tart on and we don't put the ice
cream on until the tarts are on the
plate yeah
these tarts are beautiful where's the
blowtorch stroller
good so on there okay we've got to glaze
them
okay ice cream here is it there
get in the system now okay keep your
plates over there so at least we stay
nice and tidy
i want them straight away because the
ice cream's gonna melt turn around
and put on the hot plate good go come on
please i don't want to hang around the
ice cream's melting
come on you did a great job keep it up
you have two towels to go yes they are
beautiful
absolutely beautiful well done come on
let's go
last one
next on the menu david blanket finds out
what the blind taste has thought of his
shepherd's pie
cut the crap stop acting like a
politician and get straight to the point
and the appleton blats find out if they
could be coming back to cook janet's
field calves on the final night of the
series
for dessert you got
right welcome back to the f word now
time to find out what our blind tasters
think of our shepherd's pie feeding
confidence
would like to serve yours yesterday if
you would yeah i think it will arrive on
the plate in a better state
okay yours looks very nice i have to say
it smells
very good indeed mine smells delicious
it doesn't smell too bad
right jose yeah take them away five meal
please
yeah it's very smooth
not a lot of gravy in there yeah which i
usually like
yeah if i'm gonna eat a whole one i'd
like it to go down quite easily yeah
this is quite dense this one doesn't
that's quite strong
i think the meat's a lot chunkier in
this new one without keys
the red one and this one brings out so
much more to that yeah there's a lot
more flavor it brings out the cheese as
well
okay jose come in what's the vote
well they both they liked it both they
like them both well that's flattering
isn't there what
what the winner there cut the crap stop
acting like a politician and get
straight to the point
all right it was a gordon yes
i never heard that you obviously enjoyed
the rich savory mints no for mr
blankets it was actually the texture of
the topping they liked they enjoyed
david's topping yeah
they didn't like my mints then but they
like the texture
they didn't like that they liked the
texture so prefer david's top but they
liked your bottom
but wow ah there's no answer to it
congratulations siri remember is going
on congratulations
thank you so much i'm very pleased for
you because your job's at stake of mine
as well
well listen before we go i've got a
present for you okay
yes now i've got this maid food
especially
okay as you know there you go
do you know
you can really really really go off
somewhere
thank you gordon god bless you you know
where the door is i certainly know where
the door is
and next time i'm going to let you cook
okay goodbye
david best wishes
absolutely happy to pay for it it was
perfect the pastry was
very very well cooked it wasn't soggy my
apple sauce i'm
you probably think i'm bullshitting
right here but it looks like it was
banged on amazing
jose let's go jose jose
here's the bad news if you get
14 out of 50 you're tied with the wendy
peters brigade
if you get more than 40 you're the best
brigade
and so far that means
you're top of the tree good don't open
it yet
for dessert
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
there's a strong possibility you may be
coming back
[Applause]
okay
you